thank you
I appreciate that I
I know why you're I know why you're
happy today because do you see Joe Biden
on 60 Minutes on Sunday he declared the
pandemic was over so
if you're wearing a mask you better be
robbing me
I thought it was over a year and a half
ago but anyway so this is you know and
things are getting back to normal we saw
for the first time now in a couple of
years the U.N met Putin did not show up
he has bigger problems at home did you
see this foot and he had to call up the
reserves now this is not going on but
gen Z is not having it by the way around
here we're going to talk about here it's
so interesting yeah called up 300 300
000 Russian men not good for Ukraine
because they're going to go to Ukraine
uh on the bright side it greatly reduces
the number of people who are trying to
hack my Netflix account
yeah
I tell you things are not great here but
in Russia have you seen this like 12
people and these are prominent people
have fallen out of a window
foreign
another prominent former Ally of Putin
uh died falling down the stairs pulling
down it's funny his goons were dragging
him up the stairs so they could so they
could push him down the stairs
and one of them said why are we over
complicating this
[Laughter]
and let's not forget about our friends
in Puerto Rico man they're having a
rough time there the hurricane hit that
did you see that the Red Cross still
says the people there without power uh
they need water they need blankets they
need medical supplies and a Bad Bunny
could use a bag of carrots
all right
no real I mean you know I know Trump
didn't know it but Puerto Ricans are
citizens of the United States it's uh
should never forget that and
but you know
Puerto Rico it's it's a weird you know
thing they're not a state but they're
not a country they're in this vague gray
area like Adam Levine's marriage
uh
but I tell you are you excited the
midterms are only like six weeks away
now and they say very high interest the
people are out there they're gonna go
out there and vote this is not usually
the case with the midterms but as one
guy said I just want to take part in
democracy one last time before it goes
away